for a particle that's moving in a circle
we found that when it's moving at a
constant rate of d theta/dt
and let's recall what we meant by theta
of T and here's our particle and we
introduced our polar coordinates R hat
and theta hat then we found that the
velocity was our D theta DT theta hat
and so let's assume that this quantity
is positive in which case the velocity
is pointing in the positive theta
direction and that means that everywhere
in the circle the velocity is tangential
to the circle and the magnitude is a
constant so for this case of uniform
circular motion we calculated that the
acceleration was equal to minus R D
theta DT quantity squared R hat which
means that at every point the
acceleration vector is pointing towards
the center now we can write that
acceleration vector as a component a of
our r hat where this component is given
by R times D theta DT squared it's
always negative because when you square
this quantity that's always a positive
quantity the minus sign just to remember
that means that the acceleration is
pointing inward now how can we think
about that well if we look at the
velocity vector what's happening here is
the velocity is not changing magnitude
but changing direction and if you
compare two points and let's just pick
two arbitrary points so let's remove
this acceleration for a moment and
consider two arbitrary points say at
time T 1 and T 2
so our velocity vectors are tangent the
length of these vectors are the same and
if we move them tail the tail be t2 and
take the difference Delta V where Delta
V is equal to V of T to minus V of T 1
and we can get an understanding why the
acceleration is pointing inward because
recall that acceleration by definition
is a limit as delta T goes to 0 that
means as this point approaches that
point of the change in velocity over
time and so when we look at this limit
as we shrink down our time interval
between T 2 and T and T 1 and this
vector will point towards the center of
the circle and that's why the direction
of a is in the minus R hat direction
again let's just recall that this is the
case for what we called uniform circular
motion which is defined by the condition
that D theta DT is a constant